we have some good vibes for you i like
good vibes i like investigation vibes
are good thanks to zendaya tom holland
and jacob babylon yes the spider-man no
way home-cast trip down memory lane and
watch their original audition tapes oh
man let's just say it was very hard for
them to keep a straight face bye
everyone have a great weekend
oh
so i just wait before we get started
[Applause]
my name is jacob what a cutie
this is the fact that you leave
and walked back in the scene you walk
there's an interesting katie
have you ever played beyond earth
thank you thank you
right you're up next
i was just wondering if you're nervous
about the debate is this a seraphim
well
texan call has a pretty solid look at
this is just really good
i feel like my whole audition i was like
so nervous and say the right words well
i'd say they made a good decision hey
look who would have thought
not me right now not us not us look at
us look at us good job guys wow good job
everyone